hello may I speak to Professor Yamanaka
please hello this is Adam Smith calling
from the Nobel Prize website in
Stockholm we have a tradition of
recording very short interviews with new
Nobel laureates would you be able to
speak for just a thank you well first of
all our sincere congratulations on the
award of the Nobel Prize oh thank you
very much it is a tremendous honor to me
especially I heard that I'm going to
share the prize with dr. John Gurdon so
I feel more honor because I respect him
a lot he established the principle of
gene conservation in differentiated
cells half a century ago and so there so
there was this very long run up and then
very rapidly you have transformed the
field by creating induced pluripotent
stem cells yes well I was able to
initiate my project because of his
experiment 50 years ago actually he
published his work in 1962 and that was
the year I was born so I really feel yes
great we've honored there's a lovely
symmetry about that and it shows the
progress of science and one can't be too
rushed in expecting things to happen and
Adidas the so it's the 50th anniversary
of your birth and of his publications
yeah I just found out to be 50
congratulations on that also then um so
may I ask what were you doing when the
call from Stockholm came well I was at
home I house works so I was really
surprised
you say you are actually doing some
housework you were cleaning the house or
something yes yeah I didn't expect at
all can you can you recall your initial
reaction to the call well so I was kind
of alarmed by my secretary she was
really fully still at my office so she
got the call from a call from Stockholm
and asked about my phone number so she
kind of gave me an app but still you
know I wasn't sure at all so when I
received the call I was surprised I was
almost you know I just thought wow it's
very a phone call from Stockholm that's
lovely that's very nice indeed it hasn't
been long it was only in 2006 that you
created the first IPS cells so it hasn't
been long so I feel that this is I am
able to receive this award because of
John Gurdon and also many other
researchers in the field this field has
been you know has a long long history
starting with John Gurdon so you know I
very lucky I may have played some
important role in this long history but
it is not myself who initiated this
field so that my feeling right now I
understand and it's it's so nice that
the two of you are now tied together by
the award and will be in Stockholm
together in December - when you come to
Stockholm we have a longer chance
happily to interview you and so talk
more okay but I just wanted to ask with
one final question which was what your
greatest
for stem-cell technologies are at the
moment what what do you hope that that
will be the first benefit well I really
bring this technology to clinics I
really want to help as many patients as
possible as you may know I started my
career as a surgeon 25 years ago but it
turned out I was not I am NOT talented
as a sergeant so I decided to change my
career from clinics to laboratories but
I still feel I am a doctor I am a
physician so I really want want to help
patients so my goal all my life is to
bring this technology stem cell
technology to get right to patient
clinic thank you and I understand that
that IPS cells will be in fact going
into the clinic in trials next year for
the first time okay well thank you very
much indeed and I wish you a lovely
evening of celebration and okay it was a
pleasure to talk to you thank you
congratulations again thank you very
much thank you